okay so today's video we're going to
focus on the male reproductive system so
let's go ahead and get started so we
look at the reproductive system in
general male and female or these are the
organs and the glands that produce
hormones which help to create a new
human like we see in the picture here of
the ultrasound and so around the age of
puberty now puberty might be at exact
age of puberty could be different for
everybody but let's just say it's around
age 12 age 13 this is where we start to
develop our sexual maturity our ability
to reproduce and the reason for the
picture here showing a few glands of the
endocrine system is because when we
reach the milestone of puberty the
hypothalamus and the pituitary glands
begin to release hormones by the name of
follicle stimulating hormone and
luteinizing hormone from now on I'm
really going to just call these FSH and
LH these are the two hormones that
really jumpstart of the process of
puberty and sexual maturation so now
when we focus on the male reproductive
system you know the function of the
purpose of the male reproductive system
is to produce sperm and then deliver the
sperm to the female egg through sexual
intercourse so if we're going to focus
on the production of sperm here we have
to mention the testes the testes are the
male reproductive organs that actually
produce sperm they're housed outside the
body in a protective layer of skin
called the scrotum when I say they're
housed outside the body what I mean is
they're not internal they're not stored
internally in our core and there's a
reason for this with the testes
remaining outside the main core of the
body
it keeps the testes a few degrees cooler
if the testes were actually pulled up
internally into the core of the body
it'd be too warm you know 98.6 degrees
and that extra warmth would would
prevent sperm cells from being made so
when we focus more on the testes
we mentioned earlier that during puberty
a couple hormones called FSH and LH are
released from the pituitary gland those
hormones travel through the blood down
to the testes these hormones then
stimulate the testes to produce
testosterone and this is the reason why
we see these are these effects during
the puberty years is because FSH and LH
are really first released during those
puberty years and then ultimately
testosterone
helps develop the male sexual
characteristics and ultimately per dad
helps to help the testes to produce
sperm now here are some of those male
sexual features that that that is
stimulated by testosterone you know
earlier in the school year you might
remember we discussed the process called
spermatogenesis and this topic came up
while we were talking about meiosis near
the end of meiosis in men is when
spermatogenesis takes place to produce
sperm cells and it's the location of
this other male testes so in the male
testes there are diploid cells called
spermatogonium spermatogonium is
singular matter Gonia
is plural so guys have millions and
millions of spermatogonia if you're the
process of meiosis that one
spermatogonium will divide into two
cells and then during the second process
of meiosis meiosis two those two cells
will divide into four haploid cells and
spermatogenesis is what happens after
meiosis number two is completed
following meiosis number two those four
haploid cells will go through a few
final biochemical changes that to
eventually become sperm cells and
ultimately it sperm cells are haploid
where half the total number of
chromosomes are contained so
spermatogenesis is really we have to
remember this topic from earlier in the
school year is a really important
process in the creation of sperm cells
that takes place in the male testes
so when we focus specifically on sperm
cells they are created in the testes you
can see I've just labeled testes in the
diagram but after they're created in the
testes they then travel and are stored
in the epididymis where they go through
a final maturation process now the
epididymis is a piece of tissue located
on the backside of each testicle a few
moments ago we mentioned that sperm
cells are haploid again means they have
23 chromosomes when you look in this
karyotype here you can see 23
chromosomes but they're it's half way
you want to see one chromosome three one
chromosome ten one chromosome 18 so
haploid cells contain 23 chromosomes but
the first 20 tailor what we call
autosomes you might remember from
earlier in the school year we said
autosomes are chromosomes that do not
influence sexual gender and also you'll
only find in a sperm cell a single sex
chromosome a sperm cell will either have
a single X chromosome or a single Y
chromosome if a sperm cell with a single
X chromosome fertilizes the egg the
child will to be a girl if a sperm cell
with the single Y chromosome fertilizes
the egg then the child will ultimately
be a boy sperm cells contain several
parts you can see them labeled nicely in
this picture there's the head and at the
tip of the head is what we thought is
what where we find what's called an AK
resume it's a pouch of enzymes and when
the sperm cell encounters the egg the
acrosome will release enzymes to help
dissolve and break through the outer
membrane of the egg so the sperm can
then enter and finish the process of
fertilization
well you might know that sperm cells
swim and swimming requires a whole lot
of energy and in the mid piece is where
we find a whole lot of mitochondria
mitochondria you might remember are the
organelles that produce ATP
through the process of cellular
respiration ATP is the cellular molecule
used to make a use for energy in cells
so the mitochondria are concentrated in
the mid piece producing a lot of energy
and that energy is used to help the
sperm cells swim the sperm cell has a
single flagellum and when this the
flagellum whips back and forth that
propels the sperm cell through the
female reproductive system order in
order to find and fertilize an egg you
know here's a fun little fun little
historical myth here is that for a time
period we thought that tiny humans were
once to be found inside of sperm cells
so I want to focus now on the prostate
gland another part of the male
reproductive system the prostate gland
helps to produce a fluid to nourish and
protect the sperm cells protection from
the acidic environment of the female
vagina as the sperm cells you know swim
in their process of fertilization and so
during the process of ejaculation semen
is released from the male into the
female reproductive system and semen is
a mixture of the sperm cells plus fluid
from the prostate gland and fluid from a
few other glands as well as we mention
the prostate gland I do want to mention
that prostate cancer is the most common
form of cancer in men and so when you
reach a certain age usually in your 40s
you may start to have regular prostate
examinations and you can you can see
from the picture that a doctor is
reaching up through the rectum and
feeling for growths that may appear on
the prostate gland you can see here's a
picture of a normal prostate gland and
side-by-side here's a picture of an
enlarged prostate gland and so through
you know yearly or every other year
examinations hopefully a doctor can
catch and identify if there is a
enlarged prostate gland then you can
start treatment the good news about
prostate prostate cancer is that it's
usually slow growing so if it's caught
at an early enough stage then the
treatment can begin much sooner and your
your likelihood of recovery is greater
and so when it comes to not just
prostate cancer but cancer in general
there's really three forms of treatment
you can see this person is being prepped
for radiation treatment this person is
receiving chemotherapy chemotherapy is
really the injection of drugs chemical
drugs into the bloodstream to hopefully
kill the cancer cells and then there's
also the surgical process where a
certain
surgery might be needed to simply remove
the cancerous growth and so as we now
focus on the process of fertilization
remember that this is where the fusion
of the egg and sperm occurs in order to
create a zygote you know here's a female
egg cell with 23 chromosomes in the blue
nucleus and Here Come a bunch of sperm
cells from the male only one sperm cell
is going to actually penetrate the egg
to create a diploid zygote all the other
sperm cells eventually die and so here's
a wonderful picture here of
fertilization about to happen the sperm
cell is about to break through the
membrane the membrane of the egg cell
and so we focus on the pathway that
sperm travels in order to for
fertilization to occur is right here
sperm cells are stored and housed in the
epididymis and then they travel through
a tube called the vas deferens and then
through another tube called the urethra
so if we focus in the picture right now
the black dots are showing the path that
sperm travels from the epididymis
through the vas deferens and as the
sperm cells travel through the prostate
they then pick up the the fluids to
nourish and protect them and then
ultimately the sperm cells and at this
point we can say the semen the semen
exits through the urethra into the
female reproductive system and
ultimately depending on the person
depending on the male fifty to five
hundred million sperm cells are
typically released at each single
ejaculation you know all it takes is one
sperm to fertilize one eight we've seen
this picture a few times now and here we
see a sperm cell about to penetrate the
outer membrane and fertilize an egg cell
let's not forget that in the head of
that sperm cell is a pouch of enzymes
called the acrosome
those enzymes will help to break through
and penetrate the outer membrane of the
egg cell
so what prevents more than one sperm
cell from penetrating the egg
well the moment a sperm cell penetrates
the egg an instant biochemical change
will occur to the outer membrane of the
female egg cell basically making it
impenetrable to other sperms this
prevents more than one set of DNA from
let's say two or three or four different
sperm cells from entering and trying to
fertilize with the female egg cell and
so there you have hopefully a good
introduction of the male reproductive
system you know if you're in my biology
class pause the video try to answer
these questions I'd be happy to check
your answers for accuracy either before
class or after class go ahead and pause
the video good luck